he'll see um res my name's Peter Pat
welcome back to goat simulator I [ __ ]
miss this game man it came out today
with a new patch oh look burg town no
thanks
let me lick you baby bread
yeah what what are you going oh there's
a helicopter - oh my god this is too
many new things I can't even what the
[ __ ] oh yeah we have a swimming pool I
love swimming old goats can float that's
what we know wow this is amazing I love
it finally I can be so fresh and so
clean clean
oh boy that show is fun oh God haha what
in the actual [ __ ] alright get out of my
way I got a good thing
what the hell are you doing man bro oh
god yeah headbutt was was that was that
what Jesus this place is huge
the hell am I supposed to do oh god oh
god oh god yeah yeah but root in the
hotel that sounds great let's go in here
hi guys let's be on our best behavior
here oh you scared oh you scared don't
be scared
oh yeah I'm scared ah what is that Oh
God whoa must go now this is goat god
dammit I I didn't mean to make love with
you yeah this is so awkward
go away know what the best move ever
what are you doing hey God
oh they rollercoasters are closed a well
little see a bad day get out of my way
that is a goat why are they just
randomly falling that doesn't make any
sense alright lick it yeah
yeah how aah oh no oh oh god what am i
licking exactly I just want to lick you
baby oh [ __ ] oh boy this is my favorite
roller coaster I'd avoid them all what
the hell are these people doing huh it's
not a crown yeah what's your big judge
who's that [ __ ] is that what is this
weird art go away whoa a bouncy castle I
can ride the bull ride you baby all come
on right what she's riding me what the
[ __ ]
oh she's loving it look at that [ __ ] she
just can't have enough of that goat ride
yeah that's rider you ride that goat
baby what the [ __ ] is this supposed to
happen
get off me [ __ ] you're riding the wrong
woman
you stupid home get up Oh God Oh whoa
that slipped Oh get off me woman all
right let's go the roller coaster baby
this is some kinky [ __ ] man oh god it's
so bouncy I'll bow I'll bounce
oh my god champions such balance is so
much yang ow ow ow
oh well this is pretty nice let's await
the roller coaster it looks like she has
no skeleton whatsoever where's the
roller coaster I'm the same where's my
roller coaster ah no tell are you guys
there they keep goats and cages here you
can't do that let's go it ISM I haven't
feeling I should not like this
some power batteries should spice things
up so how do we get batteries that looks
like it's a battery oh god I can put a
lot of batteries saying okay so now we
can finally uh oh there we go baby
you're ready for the ride of your life
babe let's do this
oh my god Oh what the [ __ ] was that best
ride ever let's go again yeah let's
fidgets riding me like she's never ride
a goat before alright let's pick one in
the back this time
no nevermind alright look no no no no no
no oh god no [ __ ] fell right we made it
somehow go in go in no oh god no no no
no no no no god damn it
fantastic swimming technique you got
there mr. goat how oh boy that was sure
was a great time at the funeral
damn it cinema real roller coaster park
find some money to buy some hats but I
only got the best hat ever maybe the
hotel has some money money yes
thank you very much oh god I didn't see
the windows are late let's get some hats
like I give you money now you give me
hat [ __ ] hat simulator pick a head from
the window alright we got the bike
helmet the captain's helmet the Fedora
the Mexican hat the turban or the witch
hat I'm gonna go with this one please
come again
am I wearing vote for them yes I am of
course oh boy the captain baby yeah she
loves it let's see if we can get on that
[ __ ] helicopter what the [ __ ] man day
is fantastic it's almost better eh I
didn't watch dogs oh hello
oh god now why did I do that alright now
we can land on the roof actually so
that's pretty good come on come on come
on yeah no yes
yes what are you doing here bro I told
you not to sit on the edges oh god he
flew alive I saved his life and we do it
marker go go yeah maybe there's a way to
get on top of Putin Hotel how there we
go there's an elevator I don't see they
yeah yeah it's dance party everybody to
the left everybody to the right
everybody freak the [ __ ] out
[ __ ]
yeah this is your doomsday Oh God
best party ever
yeah I'm the king of the dance floor
dance [ __ ] dance yeah [ __ ] you dating
daddy
what are you doing in my house dead goat
of course I could totally do it better
hey give me some vodka and that's it all
right there we go oh I'm dead goat yes
there's a helicopter here though I know
they're saying here we go here we go
here we go come on let on that [ __ ]
land on that [ __ ] yes I don't know
what's going on right now oh my god what
the actual [ __ ] yes yes we did it for us
I'm so happy haha
it's gay Wow [ __ ] up Oh God where are
we going I don't even know but I love it
this is beautiful Jesus copter wow I
wonder if we can hit one of those that'd
be pretty awesome and we're back at the
party
[ __ ] yeah hey man how you doing oh god
oh god I don't know what's going on here
yeah did you guys miss me or what did
you mess to me I said all right buzz I'm
sorry but I have to end this
Oh God episode there hope you enjoyed
watching go ahead and leave a like if
you want more go to and I'll see you
bros in the next episode sales embrace
love you back